[Music]
walmart's having a sale on attacks
against people who are pale
yep the critical race theory tearing us
apart is now available at walmart leaked
documents first obtained by conservative
activist chris ruffo show walmart has
trained more than a thousand employees
in critical race theory the training
denounces the us as a white supremacy
system and teaches staffers to accept
their guilt and shame and stop thinking
white is right which may explain why the
greeters now say welcome to walmart may
you die colonial oppressor
[Laughter]
walmart told the new york post owned by
our parent company fredericks of
hollywood
that employees have gone through the crt
sessions since 2018. they're reportedly
segregated by race into affinity groups
and minorities are told they suffer from
constructed racist oppression and
internalized racial inferiority
so they were segregated racially to be
told that they suffer from constructed
racism
that's like feeding people canned tuna
and garlic before telling them they have
bad breath
the company insists it's for corporate
officers and salaried managers not for
hourly workers they get session those
the workers get sessions like why you
need to stay late and how to avoid
getting trampled during a sale
you know daig and the thing that gets me
about this is that who get who actually
is the recipient of more mockery
minorities or walmart shoppers right
there's websites devoted to mocking
people who shop at walmart shouldn't
they be doing like critical critical
anti-wall shoppers
training
sorry how about how about standing up
for your customers first and foremost
every time my dad goes he gets in a
fight with somebody over some like the
last box of prilosec they could they
could crack down on that uh walmart put
my parents business under yeah so i'm
real i'm
really
really rooting for walmart but most of
walmart's executives that's who is
targeted with this programming they're
white so just give them all a cat of
nine tails tell them to
order them for some self flagellation
and let me observe run the room well
jimmy your clothes aren't even up to the
walmart standards
but what degen said is right this is an
example of corporate deflection if you
go woke the activists will overlook how
you eliminated mom and pop stores or
relying on welfare to pay subsidize your
workers and stuff like that oh it is a
problem and again we can't all shop in
the gary coleman collection
[Laughter]
[Music]
are you saying that cause he's short
well jimmy that's a that's a two-for-one
jacket you can file your toenails on it
thank you that was great did you write
that on the set of hee-haw yes
i love you both
i love you both i do think this is so
this is what's so ironic to me that
they're making employees sit through
these classes because most of my friends
who work at walmart wound up there
because they didn't sit through class
it's like they've gone kind of full
circle but this is so part and parcel of
where we are as a country right now
they're just you know attacking whitey
because white is the only safe space for
attack anymore you can't make fun of
anything in america anymore but if you
want to go in on white people you can
and it's gotten so prevalent that white
people are now going in on themselves
it's so stupid but then there's part of
me that was watching this and it's like
you know joe biden would make a great
walmart greeter if you didn't mind being
welcome to target yeah
cat uh does it make you more or less
likely to shop at walmart when you hear
this news does it matter really to you
where is a
there's a walmart in new york right no
nope not in new york city it's all it's
out on like long island i am truly a man
of the people
i mean like like dagon said all but one
of the top nine top executives are white
people so they can just quit yes exactly
exactly step out of your room they can
stop making millions of dollars make
room for money just quit
exactly but of course they don't want to
it's like you ever i mean we all have
those friends right who's like their
partner is a horrible person and they're
like oh but he's in therapy it's like
yeah he's going to therapy so he can
continue to say oh i'm in therapy when
he's really a trash human being that's
all this is but on a corporate level
they finally caught on right that's
right they go like oh we're doing this
yeah so stick with me last word to you j
cubed yeah you know now that they've
solved now that they've systematically
solved this systemic problem we have of
hating one another as human beings maybe
they can i don't know implement a dress
code so i can take my kids to walmart
and not have to cover their eyes i mean
walmart
the walton family has put more americans
out of business than joe biden and at
least joe biden had the self-respect to
pay people to not go to work they just
they just shut their business down by
selling a bunch of cheap goods i mean
this is the this is the company that
invented
black friday massacres
right i mean like everybody want to give
thanks on thanksgiving so we can go kill
each other on friday morning to get that
big screen tv that's going to quit two
weeks into it they had so much faith in
it they didn't even put their sony logo
on it because this is the one it wasn't
made in china it was made in like
cambodia you know like and so like this
company is rotten to the core as far as
i'm concerned i don't shop at walmart i
do shop at the dollar general though
because we have five dollar generals and
no jobs in my hometown so that i mean
that's the kind of that's the kind of
pariah company walmart is and uh and it
really you know come on man you're gonna
treat your employees this way i mean
when are you southwest hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else